où il ya 24 ans enfin pendant 24 ans par
dont vous avez été prof de philo un beau
jour vous avez tout plaquer vous êtes
dit bon il fait trop chaud là je m'en
vais rieurs et vous avez créé quelque
chose d'insolite ans déjà pourquoi avoir
quitté l'éducation nationale au bout de
24 ans pour vous lancer dans cette
aventure et bien j'avais envie de faire
de nouvelles expériences j'ai adoré les
24 ans pendant lesquels j'ai enseigné la
philosophie mais j'étais il ya un moment
je me suis dit la philo c'est quand même
pas seulement pour passer son bac
pas seulement pour avoir une bonne note
au bac la philo elle nous apporte
peut-être aussi autre chose
socrate ou nitoo montagny l'ont pas fait
de la philo pour avoir une bonne note au
bac est donc là je me suis dit pas ce
qui est intéressant c'est que la philo
elle nous permet de de répondre à
certaines questions existentielles que
tout le monde se pose tout le monde se
questionne sur sur des choix parfois il
faut faire des choix
sa vie l'amour voilà je me marie je me
marie pas je fais des enfants je fais
pas d'enfant et puis c'est les grandes
questions liées à la mort et c'est donc
la philo elle permet de clarifier ces
choix-là de les poser voilà le plus
clairement possible
et puis elle va apporter un certain
nombre de réponses on peut s'appuyer sur
des philosophes on peut aller chercher
tout seul aussi ses réponses
moi j'invite les personnes allez il pose
ta question et puis cherche la réponse
la plus claire que tu trouveras vous
allez vous faire une réponse claire sur
la philo mais difficile d'ici quelques
secondes je suis sûr j'en suis sûr parce
qu'on n'avait pas tout à fait répondu à
ma question mais puisqu'on est sur la
philosophie sans vraiment faire trop
élitiste justement qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui disent peut-être et
ceux qui sont là ce matin à 10h en train
de se poser cette question ou là là mais
c'est un emploi parce qu'on s'est un peu
élitiste
ça nous prend la tête sous l'eau
répondait à celle ci c'est vrai la philo
certains pensent que ça va être quelque
chose de compliqué qui est réservé à
certaines personnes laissent prennent la
tête et moi je trouve que c'est dommage
effectivement je pense qu'il ya
certaines personnes qui cela réserve un
peu qu'ils ont des discours un peu
obscur du coup on a l'impression qu'ils
sont très intelligents parce qu'on
comprend rien ce qu'ils racontent
mais moi je fais comme socrate quand je
comprends rien à ce que raconte
quelqu'un j'ai dit je comprends pas je
suis désolé mais tu peux me l'expliquer
autrement et je pense la philo c'est
quelque chose de très clair au contraire
quand on lit platon c'est très clair et
j'invite à se réconcilier avec cette
clarté
je dis pas que c'est facile pour autant
mais c'est très clair et un enfant peut
commencer à philosopher parce que je
philosophe aussi avec des petits il peut
commencer à avoir des idées des idées
claires sur qu'est ce que ça veut dire
tomber amoureux es quelle est la
différence entre un ami un amoureux un
petit enfant il peut déjà commencer à
raisonner là dessus une petite réponse
laurence parce qu'autrement n'aura pas
beaucoup le temps de parler de votre
projet c'est carré dommage parce que je
reviens sur ce camion
la philo mobile moi je dirais que le
camion pizza nourrit le corps parce que
l'on voit un camion
vous vous nourrissez l'esprit c'est
exactement voilà l'esprit on a tous bien
conscience que vont nourrir notre corps
notre esprit on n'a pas toujours l'idée
qu'il faut le faire une impression qui
se nourrit tout seul ouais alors ça veut
dire l'envoi des images vous nous parler
d'enfants ya quelques minutes
ça veut dire que ces enfants qu'est ce
qu'il faut c'est vous qui leur donnait
rendez-vous c'est eux qui voient votre
camion ce sont souvent ceux organisés
par des médiathèques des associations ou
des écoles ouais alors moi je me rend
volontiers puis vous voyez là dans le
camion bas ce jour là il n'y avait pas
de lieu d'accueil de débat on va dans le
camion puisqu'il est aménagé avec des
cons et c'est dans le camion se retrouve
alors dans le camion va réfléchir à ce
jour là justement ces jeunes filles se
questionner sur l'amour est-ce qu'il
faut tout abandonné pour un amour ou
est-ce qu'il faut ben non pas se perdre
soi-même c'est petit jeune fille de 13
ans se questionne sur qui cherchent des
hypothèses ensemble par rapport à ce
qu'elles vivent et puis c'est
intéressant de comprendre comment
l'autre pense puisqu'elles vont
dialoguer entre elles s'étaient des
petites jeunes filles et puis à toi tu
penses comme ça ah oui ça peut-être du
sens moi je pensais pas comme ça mais
cette idée là finalement elle me plait
bien ça permet de faire réfléchir un
petit peu voilà voilà en multipliant les
points de vue ouais et du coup ça
enrichit notre réflexion ça veut pas
dire quand même que ce sont des cours je
m'adresse à alla noro a dit c'est pas
une conférence oui mais là j'en ai eu
assez de faire des coups puisque quand
on fait un cours un prof au bout de 25
ans il en a assez puisque je vais vous
dire les élèves pas ils ont marre bien
avoir les mains quand est-ce qu'on
aurait peut-être la même chose
hélas pour moi ce qui est formidable
c'est que j'apprends en fait jusque là
parole s'exprimera là et puis moi
j'apprends des autres je sors d'un
atelier là il ya eu un atelier à saint
claude dernier
moi qui étais d'une richesse à quoi
incroyable parce que les personnes qui
venaient étaient très variés il y avait
des jeunes gens de 15 ans d'origine
turque des gens plus âgés des retraités
des femmes de 30 ans et chacun un point
de vue différent avec son parcours et
laurence akerys ça veut dire que quand
on s'engage ça veut dire qu'il faut être
souple ça veut dire qu'il faut accepter
les idées des autres ça veut dire qu'il
faudra parfois en contradiction c'est à
dire qu'on peut s'engueuler oui on peut
aussi s'embrasser voilà c'est ça la
discussion ces salafistes de cinq
camions
voilà c'est la philosophie tels que vous
l'entendez exactement je travaille aussi
en prison par exemple et la belle invite
les détenus à penser et à s'observer
penser quand on s'énerve mais il n'ya
pas que les détenus 20 qui tout le monde
peut s'énerver observe qu'elle est
l'émotion là qui est en train de
travailler tu te mets en colère tu dis
que tu es pas d'accord et souvent on est
tellement pris par son émotion qu'on ne
sais pas avec quelle idée on n'est pas
d'accord
laurence boucher est ce que ça veut dire
que tout le monde peut le faire ça tout
le monde tout le monde à partir du
moment où il sait parler j'aime bien
comparer ce que je fais un effort
finalement c'est ça je pense que faire
du sport oui mais son esprit ça se
travaille comme on travaille son corps
tout le monde peut faire du sport même
une personne malade même une personne
handicapée elle peut faire du sport mais
là c'est pareil
alors on va pas devenir je crois que jan
map et si on fait du sport en seront
bien sûr ou sur le plateau mais c'est
pas grave on va exercer son esprit